Prof: We are moving
towards the end of Part I,
that is, the 1605
Quixote,
and as we move towards the end,
I'm sure you will have noticed
that there are a number of
returns and repetitions which
give density to the fiction by
being cross-referenced,
as it were, within itself,
meaning that there are
characters who reappear and
incidents that are,
if not repeated exactly as
before, recall previous
incidents.
There are three such character
and/or incidents,
one of which I will discuss in
detail,
and two others that I will just
mention briefly here at the
beginning of today's lecture.
These are the galley slaves,
one;
two, is Andrés;
and three, is the postprandial
speech.
Now, the galley slaves are
mentioned again when the priest
and the barber bring up the
incident to explain their
presence at the inn,
or the presence in their
meeting Don Quixote;
they say that they were
supposed to be assaulted by
these freed prisoners as they
were on their way--
not the prisoners,
but the barber and priest--
as they were on their way to
collect some money sent from
America.
They do this to embarrass the
knight and to persuade him that
what he has done is not right,
that in fact,
it is a crime.
The priest gives a proper legal
interpretation to Don Quixote's
actions.
He has committed a crime
against the Crown,
because the galley slaves were
under its jurisdiction,
being that they were being sent
to the galleys,
that they were on the road,
and that they were being
guarded by agents of the Crown,
as opposed to other branches of
justice,
and remember that because of
the regional independence in
Spain there were various kinds
of police,
but these galley slaves were
under the purview of the Crown,
which makes Don Quixote's crime
much worse.
This prepares the second
mention of the incident of the
freeing of the galley slaves,
which is when Don Quixote is,
in fact,
nabbed by the Holy Brotherhood,
precisely for that crime.
I will speak about this later,
but notice that the characters,
who are presumably out to bring
Don Quixote to reason and to
bring him home,
go in and out of his madness
participating and expanding with
their lies his delusions;
notice that there is an
elaborate lie here that the
priest has come up with.
This is one of larger themes of
the Quixote,
that, although society cannot
cope with his madness because it
shows the arbitrariness of laws
from outside of them,
members of society are
themselves toeing a very thin
line between their compliance
with societal laws and norms,
and acting insane themselves.
Ultimately, and this may very
well be beyond anything that
Cervantes intended to do,
the figure of Don Quixote being
a mad individual questions the
very core of the rules and
regulations that sustain daily
life.
Don Quixote's most original
feature as a character of
fiction is his being insane.
It gives him a transcendence,
a certain kind of
transcendence.
He is truly the first insane
protagonist in western
literature,
and there have been others
since, but none with this kind
of transcendental form of
madness.
So that's the first of the
returns.
Two, Andrés.
Andrés
returns--remember,
that Andrés was a young
man that was young man that was
being flogged by Juan Haldudo,
and Don Quixote intervenes,
and so forth;
I'm sure you remember this
episode which took place during
Don Quixote's first sally.
Andrés returns and
reveals that what Don Quixote
did for him made his situation
worse.
This is parallel to the mention
of the galley slaves,
because it brings up that Don
Quixote's actions have had the
opposite effect of what he
intended.
In both cases,
he defends himself by saying
that he was upholding the laws
of chivalry,
which are superior to the laws
and customs of the time in which
he lives.
But the interesting detail
here, the significant detail
here,
is that Andrés is on his
way to Seville,
which, as we now know,
is the center of picaresque
life.
Seville is the center of
picaresque life,
and you will have this
reinforced when you read by the
next class,
I hope, the exemplary story
Rinconete and Cortadillo,
which takes place precisely in
Seville.
So the fact is that his return
shows or suggests
retrospectively that he was a
pícaro all along,
that he was probably guilty
when Haldudo flogged him,
so these returns cast light
retrospectively on the previous
episodes--
As I said, they established
these kind of inner world of
references in the fiction.
Sancho has to give
Andrés something to get
rid of him.
The reappearance of characters
is a narrative device that
Cervantes will use more
frequently in Part II,
which is a more tightly
structured novel.
And the return of characters is
something that some of
Cervantes's followers in the
eighteenth century,
like Henry Fielding will use,
if you have read,
if you remember,
your Tom Jones,
for instance.
The third repetition is the
postprandial speech.
This is a word,
that I'm sure,
you will never forget after
this class.
It is in Webster's dictionary,
so not it's as recherché
as it may sound to you.
It's an after dinner speech.
Now, this is the speech about
arms and letters.
The speech about arms and
letters is the repetition of the
near repetition of a similar
previous incident,
as I'm sure you have noticed.
The speech of the Golden Age
that Don Quixote delivered to
the goatherds right before the
Marcela and Grisóstomo
episode.
The speech on arms and letters
harkens back to medieval
debates, like those wine against
water, clerics against knights,
and so forth.
These were topics for
rhetorical exercises,
like those topics for a debate
between debating teams nowadays.
It was a set topic,
arms against letters.
This is the reason why Don
Quixote delivers the speech,
one of the reasons why he
delivers the speech is part of
his storehouse of topics that he
has in his mind,
but it's also true that
Cervantes did practice both arms
and letters,
and that he valued both,
as did Don Quixote himself.
The topic in the speech also
refers to utopian models of
behavior,
roles codified by the
Renaissance: the courtier,
the knight, the poet or man of
letters,
and in Spain,
the saint were models of
deportment.
Baltasar, I have left an 's'
out of his name,
Baltasare Castiglione,
who wrote a book--
you are getting progressively a
list of important Renaissance
books that you must keep in mind
when reading Cervantes--
Castiglione is 1478-1529;
he published The Book of the
Courtier in 1528.
It is a book in which these
modes of behavior are codified,
these ideal modes of behavior.
The answer to the debate,
I mean the result of the
debate,
is that the ideal is Don
Quixote's own ideal of a
reflective man of action which
will then following,
will be personified in the
captain,
who becomes the captive in the
next tale.
This is the current debate
between the politically
committed individual and the
intellectual in the ivory tower
to establish a clear cut
distinction–You know,
there are these debates about
whether you want to be a Che
Guevara,
or you want to be a great
intellectual,
o it has sort of a contemporary
relevancy,
but it is essentially a topic
of the times.
Now, again, the focus is on the
intersection between literature
and current history,
between fiction and reality.
Américo Castro,
whose name--
I am going to mention several
critics and I have put their
names here so that you know how
to write it--
Américo Castro wrote in
a book called El pensamiento
de Cervantes,
Cervantes' Thoughts,
or Cervantes' Way of
Thinking or Cervantes'
Ideas,
published in 1925,
it's a book that I believe that
I mentioned before,
but if I didn't it is one of
the best books,
the most important books about
Cervantes ever written,
because in that book
Américo Castro dispelled
the notion that Cervantes was,
as the phrase went,
an ingenio lego.
You remember the word
ingenio from one of the
earlier classes,
'wit'--Examen de ingenios
remember the book by Huarte
de San Juan,
the doctor, and remember,
'ingenio' is in the
title,
El ingenioso hidalgo Don
Quixote--
Ingenio lego meant that
Cervantes was an unlearned wit,
a natural.
That is, that Cervantes had
innate ability as a great
narrator and so forth,
but that he really lacked
culture.
This was a romantic idea,
the idea of the creator who
invents out of nothing his books
and stories and all of that.
It was also a very
nationalistic reading of
Cervantes, because those critics
say, this is the spirit of Spain
expressing itself through
Cervantes.
Américo Castro
demonstrated that this was all
hogwash,
that Cervantes was steeped in
Italian Renaissance literature
and thought,
and that therefore he was no
ingenio lego at all.
Well, in that book
Américo Castro writes,
I quote: "The debate
between arms and letters is a
harbinger of the importance that
learning and reason acquire over
traditional life.
The intellectual arm with
theoretical reason is getting
ready to intervene in the fate
of Europe"
Unquote.
Absorb that,
the intellectual arm with
theoretical reason is getting
ready to intervene in the fate
of Europe.
In other words,
government will not be just
left in the hands of kings and
aristocrats whose expertise in
ruling countries was based on
traditional knowledge and
practice passed down by
tradition,
but that the practice of
government is becoming the
object of serious and sustained
reflection.
It is the birth of political
science as a discipline that we
are witnessing in the sixteenth
century,
and that it is reflected in Don
Quixote's speech.
In this regard,
the figure to keep in mind is
Niccolò
Machiavelli,
1469-1527 and his famous
treaties called Il
principe,
The Prince,
which was written in 1513 and
published in 1532,
which is really the founding
work of political science.
I know that you may have a
vague idea of Machiavelli,
mostly centered on the
cliché
that the ends justify the means
and so forth--
I'm sure you've heard that and
attributed that as a
Machiavellian idea--
but his book is much more than
that,
it's very complicated and
complex and influential and
important.
One of Machiavelli's models,
by the way,
was Ferdinand of Aragón,
whom you have met extensively
while reading your Elliott for a
cunning ruler,
who knew how to apply the rules
of government.
Castro adds with regards to Don
Quixote's speech--by the way,
Castro is a very common last
name, it has nothing to do with
the Castro;
'castrum' in Latin meant
a military encampment,
so therefore it was very easy
for them to be many Castros in
Spanish,
so that's why there are so many
of them--
Castro adds with regards to Don
Quixote's speech,
he says the following,
and I'm going to quote
Américo Castro,
again.
He says: "We are,
again, faced with the
essentially Cervantean dualism,
epic heroic fantasy versus
reason and reflexive criticism.
At a point in his speech,
Don Quixote exclaims,
'But let us leave this aside,
because it is a labyrinth with
no easy exit.'
The fulcrum of Cervantes' soul
where both planes intersect each
other [heroic fantasy and
reasonable effort]
belongs to both;
thus this theme dwells within
him [I'm still quoting
Américo Castro]
dwells within Cervantes,
being of a primarily
formalistic nature,
but it is also the mold for the
sociological preoccupations of
the Renaissance."
Unquote.
However, Don Quixote does favor
arms over letters,
as he says, and the fact is
that he has just won the battle
with the giant,
of which the speech is a kind
of celebration,
so he opts for arms over
letters, perhaps with Cervantes
himself,
who always had a fondness for
his life as a soldier,
as you, no doubt,
noticed in reading the tale of
the captive.
So we get back to our speech
and dinner's topic.
This is the second,
again, I said postprandial
speech by Don Quixote,
the first was concerned with
the Golden Age.
The Russian critic and
theoretician Mijaíl
Bajtín,
whom I have mentioned before,
and I forgot to put his name,
but I'll put it again.
This is all,
of course, an approximation,
this name from the Russian.
Don't confuse him with these
guys.
Mijaíl Bajtín,
in his book Rabelais
gives a great deal of importance
to dinners because his metaphor
for the novel,
what the novel is like is the
dialogue and dinners are
essentially dialogic.
There is a book on
Bajtín called Bajtin's
Dialogic Imagination.
Now, François Rabelais
is yet another Renaissance
figure you must keep in mind.
He was French for a change,
not Italian,
and lived between 1492 and
1553.
He wrote these outrageous
stories about Gargantua and
Pantagruel as you may have
heard about.
Bajtín writes the
following,
that I cannot resist
quoting--Bajtín wrote
with a great deal of verve about
elements of popular culture that
were incorporated into
literature--
He says--I think he learned a
lot from Cervantes,
so much so that he doesn't
write about Cervantes because it
may have been redundant:
"Eating and drinking are
one of the most significant
manifestations of the grotesque
body [he's talking about the
grotesque bodies of these
characters in
Rabelais].
The distinctive character
of this body is its open,
unfinished nature,
its interaction with the world
[you can think of Sancho here],
these traits are most fully and
concretely revealed in the act
of eating.
The body transgresses here its
own limits;
it swallows,
devours, rends the world apart,
is enriched and grows at the
world's expense.
The encounter of man with the
world,
which takes place inside the
open biting,
rending, chewing mouth--[I'm
gonna read that sentence again,
because my mouth got a
little]--the encounter of man
with the world,
which takes place inside the
open biting,
rending, chewing mouth is one
of the most ancient and most
important objects of human
thought and imagery.
Here man tastes the world,
introduces it into his body,
makes it part of himself.
Man's awakening consciousness
could not but concentrate on
this moment,
could not help borrowing from
it a number of substantial
images determining its
interrelation with the world.
Man's encounter with the world
in the act of eating is joyful,
triumphant, he triumphs over
the world, devours it without
being devoured himself.
The limits between man and the
world are erased to man's
advantage."
Unquote.
As you can see,
in all of these scenes of
eating,
of which there will be many
more in Part II,
in which particularly Sancho is
involved in this joyful way,
the barrier between me and
reality is broken when I
incorporate reality into myself,
make it part of myself by
eating it,
and this is what is celebrated
in these postprandial speeches.
For Bajtín,
dinners are the privileged
occasion for dialogue;
dinners celebrate the end of
work and the defeat of the
world,
which is, in fact,
consumed, animals,
vegetables, wine,
which is like the blood of the
earth.
Wine loosens the tongue and the
truth comes out
unguarded--remember the Latin
phrase that I taught you before,
in vino, veritas.
Plato's Symposium,
whom I'm sure you have read,
and it's called really,
the Banquet,
'the last supper,' all mark
ritual occasions where the truth
is to be spoken over food or
after food.
There are, of course,
two other functions of the
mouth that are not mentioned
here, but that do occasionally
come into the erotic and the
aggressive.
The erotic I don't have to and
I won't go into here,
it's too obvious.
The aggressive,
of course, is to bite,
to spit, and,
as we have seen in an earlier
episode,
to vomit on somebody else,
as we saw in that dialogue of
vomits after the episode of the
sheep.
So I am assuming a bajtinean
sort of a persona as I make
these comments,
because he was so interested in
these bodily functions.
So the truth has prevailed in
the resolution of all of the
conflicts,
and Don Quixote celebrates with
his speech,
and he, the mad man,
has been the vehicle of that
resolution.
The speech also serves as a
transition to the captive's
tale, which will be narrating
episodes of war to corroborate
Don Quixote's ideas.
In fact, the captive's tale
will narrate that battle,
called the Battle of Lepanto,
whose anniversary we are
celebrating tomorrow.
The Battle of Lepanto occurred
on October seventh,
1571, so this is what I told
you at the end of last lecture
to ponder and see if you could
come up with what anniversary
was being celebrated this week;
it is the Battle of Lepanto.
The suggestion was that once
the various conflicts were
resolved Don Quixote celebrated
by his speech on arms and
letters.
Through Bajtín we
concluded that this was a moment
of truth ironically represented
through the scene of the dinner.
There seems to be a whole
tendency in the Quixote,
as we approach the end,
towards the truth that
culminates in the story of the
captive,
which is based on Cervantes'
own life and on episodes of
recent Spanish history,
but more importantly,
episodes in which Cervantes was
present.
Could Cervantes circling back
to himself be a part of this
move towards the truth?
Is it a shift away from
literary stories to stories
based on his own life,
and what does that mean?
As Ciriaco Morón Arroyo
has said--this is the second
critic I am mentioning;
he's my friend,
he was my colleague at Cornell
University,
and of course Morón
doesn't mean 'moron' as it does
in English,
so it is perfectly okay to have
such a last name in Spanish,
although for poor Ciriaco,
whom I love very much,
is in retirement now in Spain,
it was the bane of his
existence when the students at
Cornell said,
I'm going to Moron's class,
but what could he do?
Well, he mostly went then by
Ciriaco M. Arroyo.
Arroyo means 'brook,' so it's
more--
In any case,
Ciriaco Morón Arroyo
says that Cervantes has moved to
create art with the truth,
to create art out of lived
experienced.
Of course, we might add here
that Cervantes's self as author
has been presented as a sort of
thin,
ambiguous and shifting fiction,
and that what stand behind it
are these snippets of
autobiographical revelation
underlined by these self
allusions,
like those to his pastoral
romance La Galatea,
in the scrutiny of the boos
episode,
and to Rinconete and
Cortadillo as Don Quixote
leaves the inn--
This is the story you're
reading for next Thursday,
everything is made to be
coordinated in this course.
The story of Rinconete y
Cortadillo, which the
innkeeper says is among the
papers somebody there left--
I wonder who that somebody
would be--
will be included in The
Exemplary Novels,
the book that you have,
and you will be reading that
story for next Thursday--
So this is one of those
snippets, teasing allusions to
himself,
the real author of the
Quixote.
So the captive's tale is the
culmination of the group of
intertwined stories,
not quite the last one,
but it is the culmination of
the group of intertwined
stories.
It is one in which religious
conversion intimates a synthesis
of contraries that surpasses not
just social barriers,
but even transcends the
neo-platonic convergence typical
of Renaissance plots--
I will unpack this--In other
words,
this story entails not just an
unequal marriage,
that is, social inequality,
a social clash,
but a marriage that crosses
racial and religious boundaries.
So the union at the end is not
just a neo-platonic union of
Renaissance ideas;
there's union through love--I
mean, Zoraida is a Moor and a
Muslim, and Ruiz Pérez de
Viedma is a Spaniard and a
Christian.
Their union is more
transcendental because it
involves the union of these two
religions.
The tale, I maintain,
could be seen as the
counterpart of sixteenth century
Spanish mystical poetry in which
courtly love,
about which I've spoken at
length here,
and Petrarchan conventions are
adapted to express religious
fervor and union,
not merely with the beloved,
but with God.
In Spanish mystical poetry the
desire for union is not just
with the beloved,
it is the desire for a union
with God.
I'm alluding here mostly to the
poetry of Saint John of the
Cross,
1542-1591, a mystic,
and one of the greatest poets
of the Golden Age and of any
age.
So, what I'm saying is that
this captive's tale,
with this religious fusion is
sort of akin to this mystic
poetry in the Spain of the
sixteenth century,
and it is a culmination of all
of these stories because it is
much more transcendental,
what is going to be overcome is
much more transcendental.
Now, there is,
as you will see at the end,
a concluding and unfinished
story of one Vicente de la Rosa,
who's a kind of minor Don Juan
and Leandra,
who is a bit of a fool,
and it's unfinished because its
resolution would--
converges with the end of the
novel,
and, of course,
the current event cannot have
an end because it is current and
ongoing.
So that's why that story is
left unfinished,
but that is one that we will
probably talk about in the next
class,
because it's really very near
the very end of the novel.
I'm mentioning it just so as
not to leave any of these
stories unmentioned.
Now, the captive's tale follows
a traditional formula.
It has like a biblical
resonance;
the prodigal son,
the father who sets his son off
to life.
And remember,
here we encounter that
"Iglesia,
mar or casa real"
saying that I mentioned that
the young man should,
particularly if he's not an
aristocrat,
he should join the church,
go out to see to seek
adventure,
or join the retinue of a great
aristocrat or,
if possible, the king.
The story illuminates
retrospectively that of Don
Fernando;
it has provoked controversy
among critics because of his
religious background.
Francisco Márquez
Villanueva,
who was a professor at Harvard
for many years and is retired
now in Seville,
and was also my friend,
but he was no friend of Ciriaco
Morón Arroyo--
as you will see,
they debated over this story--
Márquez Villanueva
claims,
for instance,
according to Ciriaco
Morón Arroyo,
that Zoraida,
a typically Cervantean
character,
like Marcela and Dorotea,
exercises her desire for
freedom within a religious
context,
but is not motivated by
religion per se.
Religion, i.e.,
becoming a Christian,
merely allows her to be free,
even at the expense of bringing
grief to her father Agi Morato--
which I noticed that in your
translation is conflated as
Agimorato,
but in the Spanish it's Agi
Morato.
Morón Arroyo claims,
on the contrary,
that the whole tale takes place
within very precise theological
guidelines,
which he presents by quoting
mostly from Saint Thomas
Aquinas.
His point is that the issue of
baptism is dealt with in a very
strict theological way.
Zoraida has not been baptized,
as the captive says,
because she has not been in
mortal danger,
and the baptism of adults in
the Catholic Church should take
place after their learning about
the faith,
except if faced by a
life-threatening danger.
So Ciriaco observes that this
has been very closely followed
in the book.
The same is true,
he maintains,
regarding Zoraida's use of her
father's wealth and her leaving
him behind in grief;
conversion to the Christian
faith justified doing violence
to nature;
that is to say,
to relatives I quote Ciriaco
Morón Arroyo:
"Conversion to
Christianity justified any break
with natural relations of
kinship if this came into
conflict with the duty to
convert that anyone who had
learned of Christian doctrine
had." Unquote.
All of this sounds plausible,
but it is hard to imagine
Cervantes as a theologian--
I'm going to mediate between
these two Spaniards--
It is difficult to imagine
Cervantes as theologian,
and much less as a scholastic
theologian.
What he is reflecting here,
I think, it just simply the
morays of the time which were,
of course, Catholic.
Now, Morón Arroyo is
much more persuasive,
it seems to me,
when he compares Agi Morato to
Othello,
after the latter,
first threatens Zoraida,
and later pleads with her in
that very dramatic scene when
they leave him behind.
He says: "The scene in
which all of this develops is
one of the great achievements of
world literature,
in the impulse both to curse,
insult and also to cry and
plead,
Cervantes has portrayed a real
man."
Unquote--meaning--he's
referring to that very scene,
that very dramatic scene.
It's the most dramatic scene in
the whole of Part I.
Morón Arroyo is also
good when he says,
quote: "I agree with
Spitzer's definition of
Cervantean perspectivism [if you
haven't gotten there you will
when you get to the Spitzer
piece which is,
I think, the best and most
important in my
Casebook].
In terms of morals,
however, Cervantes is in no way
a perspectivist"
He says, and in a note he
adds--Ciriaco Morón
Arroyo: "Perhaps we ought
to point out here that
perspectivism is inherent in
Christian thought.
Perspectivism in the sense of a
form of modesty that recognizes
the limits of all judgment and
human knowledge is indeed
Christian humility and
intelligence in its strictest
sense.
The capacity to perceive the
limit of our own creations,
i.e., 'ironea' [then he
puts in the word in the Greek,
the original word for
irony]."
But Morón Arroyo is at
his best when he points out
referring to one critic called
González López:
"I find magnificent his
observation that the marriage
between the captive and Zoraida,
the new Christian is accepted
by the audience at the inn by
the oidor [the judge]
who has no allusion to the
impurity of blood that could
result from it."
And this is true,
once she converts to
Christianity there is no
impediment for them to marry,
and there is no stigma attached
to their issue;
although, of course,
there were, in the Spain of the
time,
stigmas attached to having
Moorish or Jewish blood,
but here there is no inkling of
it at all.
And he's also very good,
I think, when he points out:
"The Lingua franca of
berberie is the most
beautiful expression of the
efforts to communicate in that
confused world.
The story of the captive
demonstrates without any doubt
that primeval state of
communication in which hman
beings create a language if
there is none.
Algiers is an experiment with
secular communication;
the renegade love and language
are its fundamental forms of
expression,"
meaning the renegade and all of
these characters who speak this
"mongrel"
quote/unquote,
language made up of all of the
languages,
and that he says is a form of
the expression of this human
overcoming of linguistic
barriers,
because of their love and their
desire to communicate with each
other.
In terms of the captive's tale,
I would emphasize that Zoraida
is a woman of action,
that she is indeed very much
like Dorotea.
I mean, she's the one who
orchestrates the whole thing,
who gets the money for the
escape and so forth.
She is like Dorotea,
who chooses her destiny,
in her are combined figures of
the renegade,
the saint, and the seductress,
and Agi Morato is perhaps the
most dramatic and well-rounded
secondary character of Part I.
His despair at losing his
daughter,
his plea to her woving,
to accept her and his vowing,
to accept her back on her own
terms is full of pathos and of
tragic death,
in this I agree with Ciriaco
Morón Arroyo and
underline the fact that this is
a very important character in
Part I,
perhaps as I said,
the most important second
character,
the most dramatic perhaps of
the whole book parts one and two
included.
Now, we move to a very strange
episode, I want to move to a
very strange episode,
Don Quixote hanging from the
window.
That its a very strange episode
for which I have an explanation
of sorts;
I have never been able to
explain to myself this episode,
which is, of course,
Maritornes and the innkeeper's
daughter having fun at the
expense of Don Quixote--
remember?
That Don Quixote had been
aroused by the innkeeper's
daughter,
and that he had actually
grabbed Maritornes and pulled
her into bed,
bad smell and all,
and all of that.
So they are,
in a sense, getting back at him
here with this rather cruel joke
of having him hanging from the
window--
This seems to be a distorted
version,
a perversion on the part of
Maritornes and the innkeeper's
daughter of scenes in the
captive's tale,
as if every important episode
had to be projected in a
different register.
Follow me in this,
if you will,
I don't have to persuade you.
At the baño--
remember, that's what they call
the area where the captives are
kept--
the captive sees a hand through
a window–Remember?
He sees the hand of Zoraida,
it turns out--and there is an
exchange of messages with that
hand through that high window.
The window and the hand
reappear in this episode.
The relationship has no
connection in the action,
in the plot,
it is just simply a remembered
image.
To me it's like a symphonic
motif, a motif repeated and
expanded upon in a different
key.
I don't know if I can convince
you of this,
but it's the only way that I
can explain this episode,
that there are echoes and
remembrances of this window and
this hand,
and all of that,
that they appear here,
and again, it's like a musical
motif in a symphony that is
repeated.
Otherwise, it's simply another
act of cruelty against Don
Quixote of which there quite a
few throughout the book.
And you could make all kinds of
symbolic and allegorical
readings of it;
that he's hanging from the
window and his feet are just
barely touching the ground,
he can't quite touch it,
and in a way you can say that
that is Don Quixote's state in
the world,
that he's in midair,
just barely touching the ground
with his feet and all of that;
it's possible.
But I'd propose this reading of
it, as bizarre as it may be an
interpretation.
Now, I said at the end of my
last lecture,
and I repeat it today,
that we are coming to the end
of Part I.
Don't forget that Cervantes had
no idea at this point that he
would write a Part II,
so this would be the conclusion
of the novel that he began to
write,
probably, as we saw,
he began to write the novel
after Don Quixote's second
sally,
after the scrutiny of the books
and his having engaged Sancho as
his squire.
Because the two parts are bound
together,
you may not have the sense that
you are coming to an end because
you have another big chunk of
book to read,
but this is the end of Part I
that we're coming to,
and it was the end of the novel
Cervantes set out to write or
wound up writing.
Now, the sense of endings in
fiction is crucial,
as Frank Kermode established in
his wonderful book The Sense
of an Ending,
that I recommend to everyone.
Frank Kermode,
k-e-r-m-o-d-e,
Sir Frank Kermode by now.
The ending invites us to read
retrospectively into the story
that precedes it and suggests an
author's conception of history
and of the loop of life,
as it were, as his characters
meet benign or violent deaths,
as conflicts are resolved,
and as a feeling of completion
is felt by the reader.
In Aristotle's
Poetics, about
which we will be talking soon
when we meet the Cannon of
Toledo,
the Poetics establish
how plots should be ordered,
linking beginnings with ends
and both with middles.
Cervantes had that in mind,
but also the endings of
chivalric romances and
picaresque novels,
in which the plot essentially
followed by the development of
the hero's life from birth to
death,
or to the point at which the
pícaro began to
write,
which involved the death and
resurrection,
a conversion.
But the Quixote is neither.
In fact, it is not a chivalric
romance, it is not a picaresque;
it was totally new.
At best it could be said--sand
I repeat this--that it,
is the parody of a chivalric
romance, hence a deliberately
distorted version of it.
As such, it is a kind of a
meta-chivalric romance,
a chivalric romance about
chivalric romances.
So ending it will be no easy
matter for Cervantes as we shall
see, at least two strands of the
plot are closed in episodes at
Juan Palomeque's inn.
This is done by appealing to
the judicial or legal cast of
the novel which,
as we have seen,
involves the perpetration of
crimes and misdemeanors by the
protagonist and by the implied
or actual presence of
representatives of the state,
in this case, the Crown.
So the first sort of
conclusion, or conclusions,
that we have here,
have to do with resolutions,
restorations and the capture
and arrest of Don Quixote.
I pause here to explain why
this turn to the legal,
which I have explained in
further detail in my book called
Love and the Law in
Cervantes published by Yale
Press,
and which is in your
bibliography,
and of which I give you a very
brief synopsis here so that you
can understand why I read these
endings,
the endings of these episodes
in this fashion.
I have maintained in that book
that the picaresque and hence
Cervantes's novel reflects the
importance of the elaboration of
a dense and complicated legal
system in sixteenth century
Spain.
You may have observed some of
these while reading Elliott.
This increase was part in due
to the development of the
printing press,
which made the issuance and
dissemination of laws much
easier,
and also the development of a
modern state organized as a
bureaucracy to administer the
precariously united peninsula
and its vast overseas empire.
If you have read Elliott,
you understand that Spain was a
modern state in the making.
Normally, Americans have a
sense of Spain as backward,
but no, Spain here was at the
forefront of history.
This situation brought about
the creation and maintenance of
state archives in which myriads
of cases,
both criminal and civil,
were kept and classified.
The distinction criminal and
civil was not quite established
as such, although in practice it
was.
A criminal act is against the
state, in this case against the
Crown;
a civil crime is committed
against somebody else,
another person.
So the archive was a form of
state control containing many
stories from which the
picaresque novel derived or drew
its cases,
like the one involved in
Lazarillo and
Guzmán.
Lazarillo's story is like a
deposition given to a judge to
justify his present predicament.
He is the husband of an
archpriest's mistress.
Legal discourse made possible
the minute description of the
real as opposed to Renaissance
genres like the pastoral,
which gave an ideal description
of the world.
Legal discourse is,
in my theory,
the foundation of the novel,
a narrative that deals in the
beginning,
mostly with criminals like
Ginés de Pasamonte and
Lazarillo,
and continues to deal with
criminals,
and that describes as only
legal documents can describe the
business of every day life.
The intertwined stories of Part
I involving legal issues,
mostly focusing on testamentary
law read like cases taken out of
those archives.
Not so The Novel of the
Curious Impertinent that is
obviously drawn from Renaissance
Literature.
In its protagonist,
who is a fugitive from justice,
an outlaw, Cervantes has
created the first important
novelistic protagonist drawn
from the archive,
as it were.
His is the case of the insane
hidalgo who set out to
act out chivalric fantasies and
in the process committed a
series of crimes.
He is the first hero-fugitive
from justice in the western
tradition.
In the process,
Cervantes uses settings like
the despoblado,
that I have explained here,
drawn from Spanish law,
and in the Holy Brotherhood has
drawn into the fiction the
police of the times,
the depiction of a real world
for Cervantes involved a world
held together precariously by
the law,
and whose representation could
not be accomplished without
recourse to legal language and
concepts.
All of the situations in the
Quixote are framed within
legal discourse.
This is the reason why endings
begin with resolutions,
restorations and the capture of
Don Quixote--
to get back to these endings
that I'm going to now describe
and analyze these partial
endings.
The episodes at the end,
towards the end of Part I are
the climax of the first
Quixote.
Don Quixote's defeat of
Pandafilando is the culmination
of his adventures,
his most resounding feat.
These adventures,
for all of their humor and in
spite of Don Quixote's
ridiculous behavior,
are successful in bringing
about peace;
Dorotea admits as much.
Don Quixote is not an angelic
Beatrice,
whom the pilgrim meets in
the Divine Comedy towards
the end of Purgatorio as he
readies to enter Paradiso,
nor an epic hero,
like Aeneas,
who winds up founding Rome,
but he does bring about peace
and justice in the world,
that is has been his lot to be
thrown into.
This is, as I have said
earlier, part of the overall
irony of the book,
that such a preposterous figure
is the agent of Providence.
Through his intervention,
Don Fernando agrees to marry
Dorotea and make good,
on the promise that he made her
the night he stole into her room
and deflowered her,
swearing to become her husband;
Luscinda is returned to
Cardenio, who had been wronged
both by her and by Don Fernando.
Crossed marriage vows bring
these conflicts to a happy
comedy like ending,
but such elevated kind of
justice is not the only kind of
finale that takes place
at the end.
Resolution also takes place at
a legal level in the most
concrete and minute fashion,
as restitution is made to those
who have suffered injuries or
damages and are owed money as a
result.
Don Fernando and the priest
compensate the second barber and
the innkeeper,
who had been complaining about
all of the destruction to his
business,
not to mention the consumption
by the knight and his squire and
their mounts.
The second barber had had his
basin stolen and dented and his
donkey's harness had been
stolen.
Financial restitutions such as
these are a form of closure
drawn from the law.
It is what 'making whole' means
in current legal terminology.
An individual is brought back
to the state he or she was in
before the damage occurred.
Restitution is the ending to a
story that began with harm and
the decrease of one's property
or wealth.
Don Quixote,
for his part,
is finally apprehended by the
Holy Brotherhood.
This is part of the all of the
encompassing closure of the
novel's plot.
Don Quixote and Sancho had been
pursued by the Holy Brotherhood
with an order of arrest for the
knight because of his having
freed the galley slaves,
as Sancho had feared all along.
They had committed other crimes
such as killing sheep,
breaking a man's leg and
stealing property from him and
his companions.
The trooper reads the arrest
order comparing the description
in the arrest order with Don
Quixote's features in one the
most hilarious reading scenes in
the book.
I'm reading from pages 408,409
of your translation,
and I hope you have read this
before and laughed as much as I
do every time I read it:
"But one of them [the
troopers],
namely, he who had been kicked
and mauled by Don Fernando,
bethought himself that,
among some warrants he had
about him for apprehending
certain delinquents,
he had one against Don Quixote,
whom the Holy Brotherhood had
ordered to be taken into custody
for setting at liberty the
galley-slaves,
as Sancho had very justly
feared.
Having this in his head,
he had a mind to be satisfied,
whether the person of Don
Quixote answered to the
description;
and, pulling a parchment out of
his bosom, he presently found
what he looked for;
and setting himself to read
leisurely--
for he was not a great
reader--at every word he read,
he fixed his eyes on Don
Quixote, and then went on,
comparing the marks in his
warrant with the lines of Don
Quixote's physiognomy,
and found that without all
doubt he must be the person
therein described:
and,
as soon as he had satisfied
himself,
rolling up the parchment,
and holding the warrant in his
left hand,
with his right he laid so fast
a hold of Don Quixote by the
collar,
that he did not suffer him to
draw breath,
crying out aloud:
'Help the Holy Brotherhood!
and that everybody may see I
require it in earnest,
read this warrant,
wherein it is expressly
commanded to apprehend this
highway robber.'"
Unquote.
'Highway robber,' that's how
Don Quixote is described and,
in fact, literally he is.
Why is it hilarious?
Because the law should be the
ultimate and most reliable
institution in the
representation of social
reality;
particularly of individuals
entrusted with upholding it!
Yet, its agent is a kind of
dolt who can barely read;
beyond that,
because the interpretation of
the real is always problematic
and difficult as is reading
itself,
and here those difficulties are
minutely reenacted by the
trooper.
This is expressed brilliantly
by the trooper looking at each
feature of Don Quixote's after
reading it in this warrant and
comparing it with the knight.
Like Velázquez,
checking to see that what he's
painting corresponds to his
models in Las Meninas.
It's a very same act,
it's a very same moment.
Here we have authority's agent
experiencing difficulty
establishing who a person is,
and with writing,
experiences with writing,
the very vehicle through which
the new legislation establishes
its power over individuals.
One can only imagine how Don
Quixote's description was
obtained from the guards,
from whom he freed the galley
slaves taking down notes as they
spoke.
That is, the whole take on the
trials of representation
dramatized in this very,
very comical scene.
So, as you can see,
all of these restitutions are
part of the closure of the book
that belonged to the legal cast
of the novel.
But the most important within
that legal cast is the
apprehension of Don Quixote
himself by the Holy Brotherhood.
This sort of loops the plot,
as it were.
But now we will have to see how
and speak about the charade
organized to cage Don Quixote
and bring him back home,
but we will do that in the next
class.